one of so many towns and cities under
relentless attack
and in harkev it's even worse here the
city's military airfield is destroyed
[Applause]
it's the start of another round of
terror for ukraine's second city
its forces again trying to defend
themselves and their civilians
russian paratroopers are reported to be
in the outskirts of the city fighting
with ukrainian soldiers
in the capital kiev the aftermath of a
missile attack on the city's television
tower
wednesday saw a lull in the fighting and
many families took the opportunity to
make their escape
some of them getting to the outskirts by
foot and finding bridges destroyed by
ukrainian forces to hold back russian
advances
the enemy is pulling its troops closer
to the capital we are getting ready and
we will defend our city
it is beyond humanity this rocket strike
proves that for many russians our kiev
is absolutely foreign to them they don't
know a thing about our capital or about
our history but they all have orders to
erase our history erase our country
erase us all
in the south the russians are now
claiming they've taken their first
ukrainian city since the fighting began
it's the black sea port of herson
in the city of anahoda residents blocked
the road to europe's largest nuclear
power station in a standoff with the
russian forces
it's a determination shared by civilians
all over ukraine but is it enough to
avoid defeat andrew simmons al jazeera
la viv